uh what was like first of all talk about
like how you ended up on cash money for
that one project
it was just a situation man I mean you
know priority was uh you know making
some some changes at the time and me and
stunner was already homies and so it
really was just a move it was just a
play you know what I'm saying it was
just a move like like that was already
my homeboy yeah so
when I had to I had a choice either
sign a new deal with priority or sign
this deal
you know I just wanted to try something
different and cash money is like the
hottest label in the world at the moment
yeah and like yeah yeah but but but most
of all them dudes was like solid dudes
with me you know what I'm saying we
clicked that's people they would you
know I would go to New Orleans and it
was all open arms like we was family you
know what I'm saying and vice versa when
they was out here it was like that so
this was something man that we was
really trying I just wanted to like do
something different but I had been
putting I had put a lot of Records out
on priority already yeah you know so you
know when when the opportunity came
and that bag was silly for that one
record I had to do it yeah uh what was
it what was that creative process like
working with a guy like Manny fresh
because you've been in obviously in the
studio with so many other Legends like
Dr Dre yeah what was the difference
between a Manny fresh and some of the
other guys
fresh is like
like I said he the first one to give me
to just go in there and just rap just
right just don't write nothing just go
in there and just say it you know what
I'm saying and fresh work faster than
anybody I've ever seen he had cooked the
beat up right in front of you like in a
few minutes that's crazy and in his
ahead it's connected for life it's right
do the damn thing is whatever but he
cook it up right there like
quick like right in front of you you
know what I'm saying so
you know fresh one of the best ever man
for real for sure you know like I
remember at one point fresh hadn't
missed platinum in a couple it was some
years had went by and everything was
Platinum you know
that's crazy yeah now I think uh I think
Manny fresh when we think when we always
talk about the goats I feel like we
gotta keep his name in that conversation
because he kind of formed the whole
sound 100 kicked off Wayne Juve man yeah
it's crazy